Hey, David, whatever happened to the Blue
Lives Matter movement?
It's interesting because in the context of
the reopen the country protests, all of a
sudden, all of these right wingers who were
from the Blue Lives Matter movement are putting
cops lives at risk, attacking them, criticizing
them and saying that they are the forces of
government tyranny.
Are they just hypocrites or what's going on?
Yeah.
Beautifully pointed out.
So when the Black Lives Matter movement got
going, an alternative movement or an alternative
hashtag got going called Blue Lives Matter,
meaning?
OK, Black Lives Matter, meaning the lives
of black people killed by police.
But blue lives matter.
Are police lives matter.
And we need to understand, this is their perspective
that a lot of these black people were killed
by police because police were in danger.
And that's why blue lives matter.
So it's a right wing movement that wants to
minimize the issue of police violence against
black Americans and do it by propping up law
enforcement.
Now, you've seen a reversal now that you've
seen governors in many states say we've got
to stay home, businesses should close, etc.
Now that you've seen police enforcing, hey,
this park is closed, you're trespassing, you've
got to go.
You've seen police enforcing different elements
of these stay at home and distancing guidelines.
You have seen those who say respect authority
from the right say, oh, well, now you've got
a disrespect authority.
You are seeing those who say respect the police.
The police are the ones that are that are
here telling us how we should behave.
Let's behave in a way that doesn't get them
angry with us.
They are now antagonizing and harassing and
intimidating police who are guarding state
houses, for example.
They're just hypocrites that that's all it
is.
Listen, this is debt and deficit is a political
football.
They don't really care about debt and deficit
on the right.
They just use it when they can to justify
removing a Democrat and voting for a Republican
or when they want to prop up a Republican.
They say, look, they've cut the deficit even
if it's not true.
Like we're seeing under Donald Trump, just
a political football.
Small government.
Small government is for many people, there
are principled libertarians.
Sure.
But for a lot of these right wingers, small
government is a political football.
It is something to say.
But then all of a sudden they want bailouts
for this industry and bailouts for these people
and, you know, buy food from farmers and redistribute
it to people and stuff that is completely
antithetical to their worldview.
They'll always come up with some way to rationalize
it away, but they immediately abandon their
prince of.
Bolls as soon as the situation on the ground
changes and it's much the same here, guys,
there's no unique respect of law enforcement
or authority from those who say it's all about
law and order.
It's all about law and order when they want
to justify the targeting of minority neighborhoods
by law enforcement.
Right.
Hey, look, we're law and order.
You go where the crime is.
But a.
But all of sudden when it's.
Hey, wait a second.
We got it.
We got to reopen it.
You can see my roots.
I need my hair done.
I need to go buy a fertilizer as one manure
as one guy said all.
Whatever.
Now, the police are the enemies.
They are actually the perpetuators of tyranny.
And who knew when all of these gun people
were saying we need to be protected from government
tyranny?
Who knew that that meant staying at home and
watching Netflix?
That's the tyranny that apparently many of
them were imagining.
So they are hypocrites.
But it's not unique is my message.
They're hypocrites on a lot of these issues,
a lot of these.
They stake out policy positions and values
that sound good in the absence of reality.
And as soon as reality hits, sometimes for
the right reasons, sometimes for the wrong
reasons, they abandoned those principles and
go, too.
What is it that I want right now?
Because I'm essentially a petulant child like
the president astutely asked.
Glad you brought it up.
We've got a tremendous bonus show today.
It instant access to the bonus show two ways.
Become a member at Join Pastebin.com or become
a patron at Patry on dot com slash David Pakman
show.
I'll speak to you then.
Otherwise, Monday, we'll be back with a new
program.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.